[Música]
como están quiero persuadirlos y
persuadir las y reclutarlos a todos para
que creo es el mayor reto que tenemos
como país y como generación que es la
descarbonización y de eso quiero
hablarles hoy y de por qué creemos que
es el mayor reto de nuestra generación
primero quiero hablarles de unos temas
fundamentales y lo son para mí
cuando yo estaba más joven y empezaba a
leer me debatía mucho sobre esas
visiones filosóficas entre la libertad y
el determinismo el pery mínimo siendo
aquella visión de que los elementos del
entorno la genética la historia la
química son los que fijan el destino de
las personas de la historia de todo o
aquella otra visión desde la libertad y
la responsabilidad que es la voluntad y
la conciencia la que toma las decisiones
actúa en el entorno y determina el
futuro lo que se hace en la vida la
voluntad el cambio cómo cambian las
cosas y yo desde muy joven me matriculé
con esa visión de la libertad de la
responsabilidad y del cambio demostrar
la voluntad que uno quiere de ver en el
mundo en cambio con acción y decisiones
y entonces hice lo que en aquel momento
según yo era lo que había que hacer para
matricularse con el cambio
es irme del país
irma estudiar e irme a encontrar allá
las grandes respuestas sobre el cambio
que necesitábamos en costa rica para ser
un país desarrollado porque esa era mi
ambición y mi deseo yo quería ver a mi
país mejor desarrollado cambiando
y bueno eso fue lo que lo que hice y me
fui a estudiar
y encontré algunos ejemplos que para mí
fueron muy importantes por ejemplo
los temas de seguridad social el emblema
de la seguridad social hoy uno de los
mejores sistemas el national health
services de inglaterra
creado en 1946 poco después de la
segunda guerra mundial
y aquel era el estándar
la seguridad social
buenos temas de la paz
se hablaba tanto entre los estudiantes y
los profesores de la filosofía de gandhi
para llevar el movimiento
independentista de la hoy democracia más
grande del mundo como lo es india o de
las luchas por los derechos civiles de
martin luther king
y si bien aquello a mí me resonaba
había algo dentro de mí
que me hace a ver que yo también tenía
mis propias raíces pero en otra parte
sobre esto
en costa rica la seguridad social se
creó en 1941
cinco años antes que el servicio de
salud en inglaterra
y en costa rica todavía en los 40 se
abolió el ejército se suprimieron las
fuerzas armadas del todo
y se decidió vivir así en democracia
eso provocó que costa rica y aquí lo
vemos en esta constelación de
de países en su relación de
expectativa de vida en un eje
e ingresos per cápita en el otro costa
rica es el país más eficiente
siendo uno de los que no tiene más
ingresos per cápita pero sí mayor
expectativa de vida
mucho explicado por esas decisiones que
se tomaron
esta otra gráfica muestra un reciente
estudio de la universidad de costa rica
donde se contrasta que hubiera sido de
nuestro crecimiento económico en la
línea roja si hubiéramos mantenido las
fuerzas armadas y que hubiera pasado y
qué pasó
por eliminarlas nuestro crecimiento
económico
nuestra expectativa de vida nuestra
inversión en salud y en educación
pero volvamos atrás entonces un momento
hubo personas allá que tuvieron el
coraje de hacer hace 78 años y hace 70
años lo que parecía imposible
hace 78 años decir que un país pobre en
centroamérica analfabeta y una
expectativa de bien aquel momento de
menos de 50 años iba a generar un
sistema de salud solidario universal
parecía imposible
lo habían dicho no no lo hagan o decir
que un país en centroamérica va a
eliminar las fuerzas armadas para
invertir en otras cosas la gente ha
dicho no las invasiones las catástrofes
como lo van a atender y sin embargo hoy
todos sabemos que eso es una realidad
una realidad también es
que costa rica logró revertir el proceso
de deforestación
[Música]
a la década del 80 la deforestación en
costa rica llegó al 20% de su territorio
sólo pasamos de un 72% a un 23%
dramáticamente y sin embargo con
decisiones con políticas con parques
nacionales con pago de servicios
ambientales y revertimos eso y en aquel
momento mucha gente decía no se puede
hacer porque el crecimiento económico
depende de la tierra de los cultivos y
si reducen el tamaño de tierra para
cultivos no va a crecer la economía y
esta es la realidad de hoy no solo
revertimos a un 54% y de cobertura
forestal sino que la economía creció más
basado en un modelo ecoturístico un
modelo de biodiversidad y de otras
fuentes alternativas de crecimiento
hoy nosotros también como país por
decisiones valientes producimos el 99.5
de nuestra energía eléctrica de manera
limpia y renovable
principalmente hidroeléctrica la que se
muestra ahí en celeste y cada vez más
diversificada en otras fuentes y tenemos
grandes retos pero eso también se logró
por decisiones valientes de hace mucho
tiempo cuando la gente decía eso es
imposible y nosotros decidimos hacer
algo diferente
pero entonces hoy
cuál es nuestro reto generacional si ese
fueron los retos de otras generaciones
y este es el reto que le hemos lanzado
al país y al mundo es el reto de la
descarbonización es el reto de que
sigamos un crecimiento económico que nos
dé prosperidad bienestar empleo salud
felicidad a las y los costarricenses
pero que en el proceso que iniciamos ya
en un desenganche en el 2035
aproximadamente y con una meta en el
dejemos de utilizar los combustibles
fósiles en nuestra economía del todo
y cuáles son los 10 ejes de este plan
ambicioso que hemos lanzado tenemos 10
ejes de los cuales voy a abordar uno de
los principales la movilidad sostenible
el transporte público saben que estamos
construyendo dos grandes trenes
eléctricos uno urbano y otro para
de carga en el caribe esto reducirá
dramáticamente nuestras emisiones a la
vez que conecta al transporte la matriz
eléctrica limpia que ya tenemos si en
vez de importar combustibles
vamos a generar acá nuestra propia
energía renovable y limpia para
satisfacer esa demanda trabajo mucho que
lidera nuestra primera dama mi querida
esposa
también estamos haciendo una transición
al transporte liviano facilitando el
ingreso de vehículos eléctricos limpios
haciéndoles quiebres para que tengan un
ingreso fácil con un tema de impuestos
generando electrolineras y creando una
mayor demanda de combustible eléctrico
en el tema de gestión de residuos costa
rica somos un país verde y sostenible
pero somos hasta el dedo y un desastre
en la gestión de los residuos y
tendremos que rápidamente pasar al menos
a la separación básica entre orgánico e
inorgánico que se podrá ser tema de un
futuro te de c's que da para mucho pero
hacia eso tenemos que ir en un cambio
también agresivo de mentalidad y tenemos
que en este caso ir a la agricultura
sostenible porque además costa rica
puede competir en agricultura por temas
de sostenibilidad y no por temas de
cantidad
estos son mis abuelos él es francisco
alvarado berta hindú ni noemí alvarado y
manuel quesada ellos eran parte de esa
generación que hace 70 años tomó esas
decisiones valientes donde todo el mundo
decía que era imposible ellos y ellas
ninguno terminó la escuela primaria
pero toda esa generación fue capaz de
tomar esas decisiones valientes que hoy
nos dan esta oportunidad de poseer una
posición privilegiada para hacer algo
distinto para hacer un cambio somos
herederos de una tradición de innovación
y de cambio y es nuestro deber llevar
adelante esto por costa rica y por el
mundo porque está en nuestro adn y en
nuestra historia y en nuestra libertad y
nuestra voluntad
esta pieza de arte acá es la cueva
sulawesi indonesia
eso tiene aproximadamente 40 mil años de
antigüedad y si ustedes ven las manos
allí y la contrastan con sus manos con
mis manos
estamos viendo prácticamente lo mismo
no obstante eso es de
40 mil años atrás
si nos ponemos a pensar en toda la
historia que ha pasado desde ese momento
hasta hoy todas las civilizaciones
religiones política cultura ciencia
de la humanidad y llegamos hasta el día
de hoy nuestra generación la que hoy
está viva todas las personas que hoy
vivimos tenemos al menos un elemento
diferenciador con todas las generaciones
humanas anteriores
y eso esto
en la inminencia del cambio climático
porque en el último reporte de los
científicos se ha determinado que es
inminente la reducción de al menos 1.5
de los grados centígrados en temperatura
para luchar contra el cambio climático
porque si no hacemos ese cambio llegará
un punto en que no hay retorno
nuestra generación es responsable por
todas aquellas otras generaciones desde
esa cueva hasta el día de hoy de
preservar ese planeta y proyectarlo a
futuro para nuevas generaciones
estos son mis papás y esta es mi familia
en el año 2050 para cuando cierre el
plan de descarbonización
yo tendré la edad de mi papá
y gabriel tendrá aproximadamente mi edad
y para ese momento yo tendré que ser
capaz de responderle a él ya su
generación si hicimos todo lo necesario
para revertir esta situación
y espero poder tener una buena respuesta
pero además desde costa rica tenemos una
responsabilidad para con nosotros mismos
y nuestra historia para las generaciones
que nos han antecedido y también para
con el mundo de hacer lo que es correcto
no solo porque queremos sino porque
podemos gracias a nuestra democracia a
nuestra defensa de los derechos humanos
a nuestra matriz eléctrica limpia y
renovable y en nuestras condiciones
privilegiadas para el desarrollo con
esto espero reclutarlas y reclutarlos
para esta gran lucha inspiradora que es
la descarbonización que lanzamos desde
costa rica gracias
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]